continuing our discussion with the
things that open a person's heart to the
quran
the light of allah subhanahu wa
so
[Silence]
m
foreign
[Silence]
about eight or nine different things
here that
allah that are there are reasons for the
heart to be opened to the
light of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and i don't believe that ibn al-qaeda
allah intended to mention every single
thing that opens the heart
rather he mentioned
the majority of things or he mentioned a
plethora of things or the most important
of things which
which are a cause for
a person becoming guided by allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
and for a person's heart to be open to
the quran and sunnah and his meanings
the quran and sunnah are the proverbial
light of the heart
al-iman
true faith
is when a pure part of the heart
meets
the revelation of allah subhanahu wa
this is what true faith is okay
true faith
when allah speaks about iman in the
quran
okay
wherever you find iman
what he's speaking about is a pure part
of the heart
which meets the teachings and the
guidance of the quran and sunnah
correctly
when these two things unite in the heart
this is what iman is this is what faith
is
it's not enough for a person to merely
believe in something
unguidedly
and it's not enough for a person to
merely know facts without believing them
rather there has to be those two
elements in some part of the heart
you mentioned before that the heart
is a very vast
vessel it's huge
okay
it seems small
it's not
it's huge it has many layers
it's an onion every time you peel a
layer there's a layer underneath okay to
reach to the
center of the heart
and so
in the heart
the heart of every person
there is good and bad every human being
the idea here
is as the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
he said every human being is a sinner by
nature
yet the
best of sinners
that's not even a correct statement
really the best of sinners because that
articulates that there are other sinners
that are good
what's meant here is
the good lot of sinners the sinners
which are redeemable
are those who are constantly repenting
to allah subhanahu ta'ala
there's always a
two forces in the heart
clashing one is that of good and one is
that of evil
and the idea here is to purify the heart
as much as possible
and to
minimize evil as much as possible
correct
this is the idea there is no human being
without sin
there is no human being without evil
and for that matter
there are
evil people that the majority of their
heart is overcome with evil
but yet they have some good traits in
them
right
these good traits that they have does
that make them muslim
no
just these bad traits
or evil that muslims have in their heart
does that make them kuffar
no
right
so for example
the people of quraish
they glorified the kaaba
right
and they protected it and they exalted
it
and they made hajj
and they
believed in allah
these are all good things right
but did these good things make them
muslim
no
right
on the
on the on the
converse of that we have
muslims companions
who
had done some bad things right who had
committed zina or taken
or stolen or whatever it was
but did that make them non-muslims
the answer is no
so the issue is
that taheed it is the
beginning of the path and it is the path
to allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
a person does not have to heed and when
we say to heed we are speaking about
guided to heed the worship of allah
alone without any partners
so in the time of jahiliyyah
people used to give charity correct
even now people that are non-muslim they
give charity a lot of charity right
but is this charity counted as something
that they will receive reward for in the
hereafter
no
because reward in the hereafter is saved
only for
the believers
so
this is reward or goodness in the
hereafter is reserved only for believers
only
exclusively
okay
but they gave charity
is that not counted
we say
for it to be counted towards the
hereafter
there is a condition what is the
condition
that there be the element of to hate
right
a person doesn't have that element of
toheid
then that is an invalid
is an invalid act of worship
what does that mean what's an example of
that salah for instance
if a person prays
really good
a very beautiful perfect salient
everything is perfect the recitation the
direction the clothing the
rukur the sujud everything is perfect
the hoshua but they don't have wudu and
they know they don't have
is that accepted
why
because it's missing a condition
of the conditions of salah
right
likewise is the issue of
to heed and any act of worship being
accepted
is like
to your
salah
to heed to your worship is like
to your salah
if your tawheed is
correct and strong and pure
your worship will be likewise
and if it is not then your worship will
be based on it right
so we spoke about the issue of taheed
and how important it is there are many
types of shirk that people fall into
muslim and non-muslim
if you think that you are immune from
tawheed that is a very dangerous path
because ibrahim alaihissalam had
is
his second son right
his heart is his second son
his first son is
and that's why he named him
because
meaning that allah
listened to my dua and this is the
answer to my dua isma
so his second son is
is haqq right
he had isma'il after he was 80 years old
he had his heart
after he was 90 or 100 years old it's a
difference of opinion
right
this half came
around the time of the destruction of
the people of lut correct
now
what was the dua of ibrahim
after
this happened ismail
ibrahimovic so part of his dua was that
alhamdulillah
that allah blessed me with isma'il in
his
even though i was such a decrepit
old man at the time
indeed my lord does answer the dua
but he also made in that dua he said
so after about a hundred years
of tawheed and calling to taheed and as
a messenger of allah and after a hundred
years
of hijrah and fighting for the sake of
allah and calling to tawheed
he's still making dua my lord please
prevent me and my children from falling
into the worship of idols
he's still afraid of worshipping idols
after all that
right
so who of us now is going to be
feel safe that they're tell hate is
completely pure
and that they're fine
but
ibrahim doesn't share that sentiment
about himself
is something that has to be
reflected on
and it has to be
it has to be examined on a daily basis
and there are many things that will
that will decrease a person's still heat
there are many things that will
introduce into a person's life
some examples of that in our popular
culture
of things that are shirk
right
is
or are
for the example
wearing talismans
right charms
that this charm will keep you safe or
this charm will
protect you from evil eye or
right
even if you wear it just for fun
i don't i don't understand that actually
you know
you tell people you know for
example that eye that blue eye right
they call it the eye of fatima
huh and philistine we used to call
in
right okay
so this blue eye i mean it's ugly
first of all to me in my opinion but
that's just my opinion but second of all
they wear it
in jewelry and stuff and it's catching
on now in popular culture
and you tell someone hey you know that's
a type of shirk you know
it's haram to put that on your body or
in your clothing or in your house
they say well i'm just it's just for fun
i don't understand what the fun is i
mean skiing is fun right or it's like
snowboarding is fun or roller skating or
shooting arrows or skydiving
they're that's fun
how is hanging talismans that
resurrect
the ancient warship of idols fun i don't
understand that
i don't understand that response i never
have understood that response it's just
it's just for fun you know what i mean
this is a type of shirk
a group of men came to
came to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
to give baya to him
to pledge allegiance to him
and
the way they would pledge allegiance to
him is they would put their hand in his
hand and he would mention certain things
to them and they would repeat repeat i
pledge allegiance to
uphold such and such and refrain from
such and such whatever it is
and so
he went through with all of these men
until he reached the final man
who he ignored completely
he didn't talk to him he didn't take his
hand he ignored him
clearly
and so
far
why have you ignored our friend here
that came with us as well
why have you not accepted his bail on
taking his hand as well
he said
he has a charm on his hand
he used to put a a little string
that they would believe would keep
fever away right
or they used to put certain
charms on their
wrists
right that they would believe that would
ward off the evil eye or that it would
ward off illness or that it would bring
good luck
it's made of different things okay
but the point is is that
the belief was that this thing could
by the will of allah
okay
repel
or bring
something good
and so
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said he has a
he has a talisman on his hand i don't
even want his hand touching my hand with
that one with that thing on it
right
what's the point think about it think
about that for a second
so he's pl he's putting his hand into
the hand of the messenger of allah
the pure hand of tawheed the hand that
has been sent to demolish
shirk
so he's got a talisman on his hand
and he's putting that same hand into the
hand of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
to
pledge allegiance to him to tell hate
out the gates you've already ish
you've already
invalidated a portion of that allegiance
correct
so what's the point
he said in the femima
and so the man heard him and ripped it
off and threw it out and then the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
acknowledged him and accepted his
allegiance
this is one example
right
different cultures have different things
that they do
example in yemen
they put a piece of steel or a piece of
iron underneath their children's
pillows at night right
in places in africa they have a
a
bracelet that is made out of metal or
brass okay
another example is when you go to cvs or
walgreens and you see those
you see those brass bracelets
supposedly that it will help you with
arthritis you know what i'm talking
about
you guys know what i'm talking about
and you read the package and it says
ancient romans used to believe as soon
as you read that that's it that's the
end of that right
that's a rule of thumb okay
ancient romans used to believe ancient
greeks used to believe ancient persians
used to believe
ancient hindus used to believe
but this is supposed to help for
arthritis this is supposed to this is
all a type of shirk
it's all a type of shirk
likewise one of the types of shirk is
that they would
in the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
they would take the weather
what is a water
a wetter
wetter
is the
albe
alba is a tendon
that they would get out of a camel's leg
you know the tendons
right it's a rope
and they would slaughter a camel they
would take that and they would make it
the
string for their bows
for their bows to shoot arrows with okay
well you know you shoot it long enough
long enough long enough it gets
stretched out and the bow loses power so
it needs to be changed right so they've
been to war with these with this bow
okay
so they have a special connection to the
bow
so when they take that
tendon out that water
what they do is they
turn it into a talisman and hang it on
their horse their war horse
they would hang it on themselves or put
it on their wrist or put it on their
swords as a handle right
and this is for good luck
you understand
this is another type of ship
we have the same thing you know this is
my lucky belt or my lucky
whatever whatever it is i mean you guys
get the idea correct
the lucky rabbit's foot
which is strange
as the rabbit
it didn't benefit the rabbit
right the rabbit got its foot cut off
so it was of zero use to the rabbit
itself
but somehow
after it was
it proved to fail the rabbit itself
it's gonna actually be lucky for me i
don't understand that mindset anyways
you tell people about these things and
they say this is just for
this is just for fun
again
the fun i don't understand how we equate
that with fun
another type of shirk which is
something that
a lot of people don't realize and think
about in our time is
another
which are horoscopes
you know horoscopes
this one is a leo and this one is a
cancer and this one is a right you know
horoscopes
depending on what
month you were born in
you flip the page in any
newspaper
and they will give you
what is expected for you
during that
during that month or during that day all
right
today if you're a leo
and blah blah blah
you're gonna have you know
and it's always something very vague
that could apply to anybody you know
you're going to meet someone that's
going to affect your life very much
today i mean that could be the bus
driver you know that will affect my life
a lot that he's going to drive me where
i need to go
there's
it's it's always just very v general
things
okay
which distinguishes
a
magician a sorcerer a soothsayer a
serger
from a
prophet right
so allah subhanahu wa says
what does that mean
he is not withholding of the unseen that
he knows of it
so when you ask him a question the
prophet salallahu sallam he gives you a
direct answer he doesn't give you some
vague answer
that
seems to be he's trying to wiggle
out of
being caught as an
as an imposter
this is contrary to
to
you know
psychics and these people
you ask them a specific question they
give you a general answer that if you
told any tom dick and harry would apply
to them some way
right
and so the point is is that horoscopes
are a type of kahana
the prophet salallahu wasallam said
[Silence]
he said
whoever learns the horoscopes then they
have learned a portion of magic which
allah has prohibited and made kufur
and the more he increases that knowledge
the more of it he delves into
right
so this is a type of shirk
and
i know this is going to sound silly
another type of shirk is
chinese fortune cookies
the ones that are sold at panda express
okay
so
chinese fortune cookies okay
that sounds silly right you know why it
sounds silly
it sounds silly because it's so
widespread everybody's doing it so it
sounds silly
you know
it's kind of music
if you say music is haram
or if you say all of the four imams
agree that music is hard on
or if you say that
islam
foreign
[Silence]
is
when things become extremely widespread
it will seem impossible that these
things are haram
right
we said horoscopes and fortune cook
cookies
and riba and
right it's almost impossible to
believe that these things are haram
not because there's any reasonable
response to why they are
not haram
if you were to example sit down and
put aside
the implications
what does that mean put aside the
implications
meaning if riba is haram that means that
this and this and this and this and this
is haram no put all that aside
let's just focus on the premise okay
ribba is haram
give me a reason why it is
okay
a person logically cannot come up with
the reason why it's had
cannot come up with a reason why it is
even considered to be something
acceptable
it's of the worst of evils that you can
do to another human being
a person comes to you in
in need
and instead of helping them in their
need you compound their need
isn't that what it is
so if you need money this year next year
how what is going to be the difference
how are you going to not need more money
because now you owe this money now you
are going to or more money next year
and this is why the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam said
that the person of riba
who takes riba
this is how he is tortured in his grave
until the day of resurrection
you guys ready to hear this
he is going to be swimming in a river of
blood
he can barely keep his head above water
you ever tread water
you ever try to tread water in a river
that's trying to take you downstream and
trying to stay
and every time he gets close to the bank
to crawl out of the river of blood
there's an angel there with a pile of
rocks
and he will take a rock and he will
throw it into the mouth of the
person who is in that river
and he will flip back and he will gargle
and he will try to swim back out and
spit the rock out of his mouth and try
to come back to the shore and he will
continue to do that until the day of
resurrection
right this is what the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
is the
recompense of a person who takes riba
in
the grave as is
it
likewise is the issue of horoscopes i
mean it's god come on it's just for fun
we don't believe it we're just doing it
right
well
horoscopes claim to tell you the future
don't they
isn't that what they do
well what the prophet salallahu sallam
said about that subject is
whoever goes to
a fortune teller
allah will not accept his prayer for 40
days
and the scholars of islam have mentioned
horoscopes fall into that category
and likewise
fortune cookies
right
but we don't believe him yeah of course
you don't believe him right
because if you did believe him the
prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam said
whoever goes to a fortune teller and
believes what he says has disbelieved
and what allah has sent down to muhammad
salla
right
and so there are many types of shirk and
there are things that are also
prohibited because they lead to shirk
there are other things which are
prohibited because they
lead to shirik what does that mean they
lead to shirk
like
putting lights on graves this is
prohibited in islam
it says hold on
building a grave up
more than a hand span
right
this is also haram
this is a prohibition in islam
there are many things which are
prohibited not because they are shirk
because they can lead to shirk
okay
i want to
meditate on a verse before we close out
for tonight
a statement of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
that says
[Silence]
m
is
[Silence]
foreign
is
[Silence]
and so the statement of allah wa ta'ala
and whoever desires a religion other
than the religion of islam it will never
be accepted from him
this verse
has a holistic meaning and it has a
specific meaning
holistically whoever desires a religion
a complete religion other than the
complete religion of islam this person
obviously is a catholic correct
a person desires christianity desires
judaism desires
you know hinduism buddhism whatever
aside from the religion of islam then it
will never be accepted from him
but this also means
certain things from those religions
right
and so people
will
also the verse means and whoever desires
elements of other religions
other than the elements of the religion
of islam those elements will never be
accepted from them and that is what we
call
and that is what we call buddha that is
what we call
innovation in islam
right
call this innovation
this is important i think that some
people don't understand how important
this is
and i think that a lot of us don't
understand how critical toheed is and
how dangerous shirk is
and how
profoundly
enveloped we are in our environment by
shirk
okay
so we see catholics
they wear the rosary right
with the with the with the cross on
it
and then we see muslims they wear the
misbaha with the maiden on it
right
hashem you know to look like
catholics right
or for example
muslims that go to yoga class
there's another one
right
or they practice
eastern meditation
muslims doing this they don't know what
they have
so now they read in cosmopol you know
the sister reads in cosmopolitan
magazine or she reads in whatever she's
reading right
and she reads that
every day for 15 minutes sit and focus
on your breathing and think clear your
mind and think about nothing else
so she starts doing this you know what
this is
or develop for yourself a mantra right
so what is the mantra
i am great i am great or whatever it is
okay
huh
this is their mantra and you keep
repeating it in your head
focusing on your breathing you may put
someone some little music and
with the
you know birds whistling and
just thinking about right this is all
taken from eastern
idol warship all of it
and we have some i had
i had some
egyptian guy he
oh i have stories i could tell you i had
an egyptian guy that
invited me
new york
to go to a yoga
temple
okay whatever
and give dawah islamic tawa to the to
the people there so you know i went and
i
sat and i told them about islam and i
told them about
and so then he called me later and he
said listen we want to start yoga
classes in the masjid now
so that's that's what we need now other
linocus right
you need to have the
jeb
right
with nefa
imagine it in your mind's eye for a
moment right
we have our yoga session and then we
have our salah what kind of idiocy is
this sit and sit and meditate and focus
on your breathing what about saleh what
is saleh
what is salah
isn't meditation isn't that what it is
but it's not unguided meditation like
the polytheists idol worshipers have
unguided meditation
we have guided meditation what is guided
meditation
we are told
what to say in what position
right
and to read the quran that's meditation
so instead of a person throwing away the
magazine and saying let me pray to reka
every morning as the prophet sallallahu
alaihi said for you to do
let me have 15 minutes meditation like
the pretty lady in the magazine said i
should do because she's a psychologist
and psychologists say and statistics say
and blah blah blah blah blah right
what does this do to a person still hate
it absolutely crumbles it
and before we know it islam is going to
become so strange
that we won't even recognize it
and a good question to ask yourself is
when asa bin maryam
comes back to earth
if that happens in our time is he going
to recognize you as a muslim or not
i want you to think about that
when isabel and maryam comes back to
break the cross and slaughter the pig
when he comes back to yada algizia
is he going to recognize us as muslims
or is he going to recognize us as
people that look muslims but
their lives reflect nothing of that
islam
that's his very scary thoughts
it's enough for tonight which is